sono riccardo bagaini atleta della
nazionale italiana paralimpica di
atletica leggera sono di orta san giulio
ho vent'anni e sonate svizzera pratt col
dirvi perché sono nato in svizzera
un giorno un medico di milano ha
consigliato i miei genitori di farmi
nascere la al santa lucia gusto perché
aveva capito che c'era qualcosa che non
andava aveva proprio ragione perché è
sommato senza un braccio ma all'inizio
questo fu un trauma per i miei genitori
perché si sentivano in colpa non
capivano perché è proprio loro dovesse
capitare una cosa del genere e non
capivano come mai cosa avevano fatto di
sbagliato
e invece purtroppo è la casualità e allo
stesso tempo dico per fortuna che ci è
capitato a me per fortuna perché ho
degli amici o dei familiari che mi hanno
saputo insegnare la normalità ovvero di
fare tutte le cose allo stesso modo
infatti io fino a 6 anni non ho avuto
nessun problema non mi sono neanche reso
conto di esser diverso
questo perché quando un bambino nasce
con i capelli biondi
lui è convinto che la normalità sia
nascere biondo io sono nato senza un
braccio
per me la normalità e rice senza un
braccio fare tutte le cose senza un
braccio e quindi questa motivazione che
avevo questa spinta in più che avevo mi
ha portato a ritenere anche giusto che
io nascessi così e sono anche contento
che capitato mai e che noi è capitato a
un'altra persona che magari poteva per
rimanerci più male è avere una vita più
difficile di quella che sto vivendo io
questo grazie allo sport lo sport per me
è vita lo spot è quello che mi ha
permesso di esprimermi per ciò che mi è
stato tolto e quello che mi ha
l'atletica leggera che non iniziata
tramite la scuola perché sono giocavo a
calcio
poi ho cambiato scuola alle medie e il
professor di motorio mi ha detto
ricky vieni qui avvicinati un po perché
non proviamo ad andare a fare la corsa
campestre e così da lì ho iniziato il
mio piccolo percorso perché sono ai
provinciali regionali nazionali e mi
sono innamorato completamente di questo
sport e quindi ho detto andiamo andiamo
continuiamo continuiamo puntiamo sempre
più in alto
e ora sono lì lì che mi gioco gli
europei che mi gioco la qualificazione
per tokyo e questo lo devo allo sport
perché lo sport quello che ci rende
tutti uguali tutti allo stesso punto
tutti allo stesso modo lo sport non
guarda in faccia nessuno
la medaglia è lì e bisogna vincerla che
non è un braccio che non è una gamba
la medaglia è sempre quella e e questa
sensazione che mi ha dato lo sport fin
dall'inizio mi è piaciuta
e infatti mi sono innamorato quando per
la disabilità spesso tendiamo a
denigrare una persona soltanto perché è
una mancanza però più che la mancanza
secondo me la vera disabilità viene
creata spesso purtroppo dai genitori
perché quel senso di colpa che hanno
rispetto ad esempio al figlio li porta a
aiutarli fin troppo nel senso che l'iper
protezione dei genitori nei ruoli dei
figli spesso causa la vera disabilità è
quello secondo me il top era più grande
perché il bambino si abitua a fare tutte
le cose come una persona normale se così
posso definirla e cliccate nella vera
disabilità e questo per me è un
dispiacere perché alla fine io di scarpe
me ne so allacciare anche senza
quindi non penso che sia così tanto
difficile fare tutte le altre abitudini
quotidiane
infatti secondo me la disabilità noi la
perdiamo quando facciamo a fare tutto
perché se riesce a fare tutto
allora cosa qual è il tuo impedimento e
quindi secondo me la vera disabilità sta
proprio in quelle singole cose in quelle
piccole cose che fai fatica o magari e
farle ai fatica a superarla perché è
vero bisogna contare una cosa che spesso
quando succedono costi traumi al 50 per
cento di scelta poi decidere se
accettati e vivere così come sei
oppure morire un po internamente dire
noi non ce la faccio non ce la faccio
non ce la faccio e vedere il buio perché
c'è anche questo a tener conto che non è
che è solo quello che noi abbiamo
passato e sono tante citazioni piccole
citazioni che però sono molto difficile
superare
quando io mi sono reso conto di essere
così ho avuto momenti bui non lo
nascondo però è più bello parlare dei
momenti felici dei momenti che ho capito
che da sfortuna e da una problematica e
velluti raf war iii invece la bellezza
di quello e sfruttarla quando andiamo
ristorante con i miei amici io esco dal
ristorante che tutti sanno che non un
braccio perché se c'è da tagliare la
pizza faccio fatica e quindi devono
capirlo tutti che io faccio fatica e
metterla su la risata secondo me
sull'ironia e la cosa migliore perché se
tu ci scherzi vuol dire che l'hai già
accettata questa cosa e li hai suo
passato questo questo problema che
magari ti affligge tanti anni ma che poi
alla fine devi vedere anche le cose
belle le cose buone
e secondo me questa è la vera il via la
segreta disabilità
magari scherzarci un po sopra e passare
avanti perché dopo che è passato questo
problema non hai paura di niente altro
assolutamente di nient'altro e scopri
mondi nuovi cose belle come lo sport
come l'atletica
ecco questo è un po il riassunto alla
vita perché in questi vent'anni ho avuto
momenti bui i momenti tristi ma allo
stesso tempo tante gioie e per questo
ringrazio i miei genitori e la mia
famiglia e lo sport per lo sport ci
rende liberi
ecco questa mia società
vi ringrazio e spero di avervi lasciato
un piccolo messaggio
nonostante i miei 20 anni di esperienza
che sono niente confronto magari agli
altri però ci tenevo a dirmi questo